a massive sign announces the location
a semi-truck passes by framing the
subject a dejected young man sitting in
the gravel by the door
a shadowy figure steps into frame
he hesitates for a moment as if
assessing the scene in front of him
the camera tracks with the figure as he
approaches the young man
this is the first shot paul thomas
anderson puts to screen in a feature
film and it's as confident and assured
as anything he'll do throughout his
career
the technical aspects of this shot stand
out but it's the first few lines of the
film that really catch my attention
hey
hey
what
you want a cup of coffee
you want a cigarette
what
i'm a guy that's offering to give you a
cigarette
buy a cup of coffee
how does one attempt to summarize the
career of a writer director like paul
thomas anderson
his filmography is as sprawling and
varied as the cast and narrative in one
of his early films
he starts with a sideways half gangster
half gambling film that ends up being
more about fatherhood than anything else
and he goes on to make period pieces
that deal with the rise of the oil
industry in california at the turn of
the 20th century
the birth of scientology and london
fashion in the 50s
the nixon era and hippie culture in the
70s
and the porn industry in the 70s and 80s
these films range from comedic neo-noir
and twisted romantic comedy to darkly
intense dramas
and strange liminal films in between
besides those he made a bizarre sort of
lynchian adam sandler rom-com you don't
have a boyfriend or anything do you
and a manic maximalist ensemble
melodrama you don't call him you don't
know to get involved in this business
episode all the while lurking underneath
the surface of all the characters in all
these times and places is a persistent
sort of loneliness a difficulty finding
connection and a sense of corrupted
ideals
i have a love in my life
it makes me stronger than anything you
can imagine
pta has these monolithic male characters
that often make declarative statements
about who they are i do many many things
i am a writer a doctor a nuclear
physicist a theoretical philosopher
but above all i am a man
but these statements are often a kind of
misdirection obscuring the character's
true nature i'm an oil man
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
i have numerous concerns spread across
this state
i have many wells flowing at many
thousand barrels per day i like to think
of myself as an oil man sure daniel
plainview is an oil man but that's
perhaps the most benign description of
his character it's how he represents
himself to others but we see him as a
liar statements he makes are often
juxtaposed with footage that directly
contradict his claims i encourage my men
to bring their families as well
of course it makes for an ever so much
more rewarding life the daniel plainview
we see on screen as a man gripped by
anger envy and greed a false prophet who
promises prosperity to a community but
who seeks only his personal gain
i'm a guy that's offering to give you a
cigarette
buy a cup of coffee sydney the character
the film heart 8 was originally titled
after until the studio got involved and
took control away from freshman director
paul thomas anderson ends up being much
more than a guy offering a cigarette and
a cup of coffee sydney offers john a
sort of paternalistic guidance did you
finish that 20
almost
it just up
the audience has a sense he's being
taken under sydney's wing and recruited
for something but we don't know what and
we'll spend the rest of the film slowly
discovering the true nature of the
dynamic of this relationship pta centers
most of his films around such a
relationship and boogie night's jack
horner spots a waiter in the opening
scene
in punch drunk love lena appears just as
mysteriously as the piano in the street
a few moments earlier
it's always these moments of chance
meeting that set pta stories down their
path
a pta film has its own bizarre sort of
structure the traditional three acts are
gone the inciting incident is almost
always two characters entering each
other's orbit the suicide
i am its commander yes
and we simply follow that connection and
its developments on whatever linear
orbital spiraling or divergent path it
takes us i'd
love to get you
on a slow
boat to china
all to myself
alone
unlike some of the other contemporary
american male auteurs it's difficult to
view pta's filmography as a clear
stylistic progression at least in visual
terms if you plotted a trajectory for
where you thought anderson's later films
would end up based on his first three i
doubt many would have predicted phantom
thread stylistically in his first three
pta is a natural extension of his new
hollywood influences already developing
and using long steadicam shots in heart
eight the showy opening of boogie nights
is frequently compared to scorsese's
famous steadicam sequence from
goodfellas in fact the latter half of
boogie nights in a lot of ways plays
like an expansion of this drug and
paranoia-fueled climactic sequence from
goodfellas and the film ends on a note
that undeniably echoes the ending of
raging bull
each of his first three films feels like
a progression along a stylistic path
that merges robert altman's ensemble
cast and meandering narrative structure
with intensely active almost frenetic
camera work that feels largely informed
by scorsese's filmography but he's not
merely regurgitating these styles he's
heightening them intensifying and
amplifying very quickly anderson is
establishing himself as a bold and
intuitive director committing to
surprising choices that often pay off
it's cosmo
i want you to go to your white
your white books but after magnolia his
filmography stylistically takes an
interesting turn
so how do we get from these sprawling
narratives ensemble casts and large
amounts of dramatic intensity and
frenetic camera movement to the quiet
focused fairly linear gentle drama with
the almost static camera of phantom
thread
examined in only visual and structural
terms the two extremes of his style we
see in magnolia on phantom thread i'm
buttering my toes and not moving too
much that's too much it might seem to
have little connective tissue so how
does pta get from this north american
teacher's foundation and we do try to
keep our standards high and that's why
we are the longest learning quiz show in
television history i want to say
something
the pivot in anderson's stylistic
development can be seen primarily from
magnolia through there will be blood up
through magnolia we see a director who
worked primarily with energy intensity
mood and the momentum of editing the
camera was important but the emphasis
was geared towards what the camera was
doing over what the camera was seeing
but around punch drunk love we see a
shift towards an emphasis on image
itself composition and light begin to
gain priority this trend continues to
develop and there will be blood
composition gains even more importance
pta is seeming to gain a greater handle
on the power available even in just how
you frame a static shot and while camera
movement still plays a vital role it
becomes more subtle and hidden from our
view by the time we get to the master
the camera moves even less and the
composition and lighting of each
individual frame takes center stage
long takes are still used but the slowly
unfolding compositions like we see here
are a far cry from the showy complicated
movements of his earlier films
i think it's an incredibly interesting
stylistic development for a director to
make his first three films established
anderson's bold command of the camera
but while his formal decisiveness
remains some of his showiness begins to
fall away into a more restrained clarity
and simplicity later in his career
and when it comes to light and texture i
think the master inherent vice and
phantom thread are three of the most
beautifully photographed films of their
decade this shift towards simplicity
whether entirely conscious or just
symptomatic of a change in the kinds of
stories anderson is telling later in his
life has allowed for what i think is
truly the most interesting element of
pta's work to take center stage
i try as hard as i can to not do the
writing to let the character do the
writing so hopefully you're getting into
a state of kind of auto hypnosis where
the characters are kind of doing making
choices and things are happening to them
that can
eventually formulate a story this coffee
shop scene where these two guys meet it
used to be a sort of notion of mine i
guess it still is that if you don't know
what you're writing just put two people
in a coffee shop and have them start
talking and it will eventually figure
itself out and that's kind of what
happened this movie just sort of started
writing itself just get two people
talking and if you don't know what
they're saying but you know one of the
guys he's gonna lead everything you know
and guide you and the movie will come
throw him in a situation with somebody
who who has a huge appetite for life and
is asking him questions questions that
he probably
is not asking himself
and you
you i suppose i guess that's the basics
of a story
my favorite moment in my favorite pta
film comes towards the end of phantom
thread alma serves reynolds an omelette
non-fatally poisoned with mushrooms
she's poisoned him before discovering
that making him sick is the only way to
get him to relinquish the vice grip of
control with which he holds life
as he goes to eat reynolds suspects alma
he never says this but it's clear just
through daniel day-lewis's performance
[Music]
and at this moment the full complexity
of the dynamic of this relationship
plays out between them without even a
word being spoken
the context of alma much earlier in the
film saying if you want to have a
staring contest with me you will lose
hangs over this moment
and reynolds in his utterly childish
need for control attempts to assert that
control by showing alma he's knowingly
accepting her poison you need to settle
down a little
earlier in the film like any good pta
character reynolds makes a declarative
statement about who he is
i'm incurable
one that perhaps more than any other
that a pta character makes is true at
face value
i can imagine the definition of
incurable being somebody for whom the
only cure seems to be making them sick
this dynamic of i need you but you're my
poison is a thread running throughout
anderson's entire filmography right back
to hard eight sydney's adoptive fatherly
care for john leads john down a dark
path i said on the phone you know
it's kind of screwed up
yeah so
open the door let's see what's going on
and is born out of sydney's own twisted
desire for redemption jack is another
surrogate father offering eddie an
escape but also the thing that is
ultimately his downfall freddy quell is
the ultimate patient for lancaster dodd
but also the symbol of the failure of
dodd's own practices
not too many places i could go with this
stock
shasta faye is the ex-old lady that doc
just can't let go of but who entangles
doc in the nasty underbelly of la almost
getting him killed
and daniel plainview and eli sunday and
perhaps the darkest incarnation of this
dynamic in any of pta's films
simultaneously rely on and sabotage each
other almost building each other up so
they have a greater opponent to later
tear down look at me
you're lower than a bastard
do your past failures bother you
no
do your past failures bother you
no
do your past failures bother you
i always feel like i'm discovering a pta
film from the inside out
pta at his best doesn't establish
stories he establishes characters
everything that surrounds them becomes a
sort of backdrop to the complicated
drama that plays out between them there
will be blood isn't really a story about
oil it's a story about a father and son
and two rivals
the master isn't really about
scientology heart ate about gambling nor
phantom thread about dressmaking these
films are about the characters at their
core
and the often confounding dynamics
between those characters i'm not gonna
let anything happen to you
for a while magnolia was my favorite pta
film the first few times i watched it i
was enthralled i didn't really
understand it but i didn't need to the
moment spent within its web of
characters felt like a series of
revelations each moment carrying itself
while they all built together towards a
moment of emotional cataclysm
but for me now what anderson does in the
midst of phantom thread's gentle
restraint says more than magnolia
manages to even with all its ambition
it reveals a director who has found that
less is perhaps more that a camera that
disappears as it slowly eases towards
our characters can grab an audience even
tighter than one that wows us with its
intricacy and that the quiet drama that
plays out on an actor's face can
sometimes mean more than a torrent of
words and tears
anderson's films are inseparable from
his characters because for him they're
not a vehicle he's using to carry the
plot or the film's themes they are
figures out of which the film's themes
and plot organically arise
and i think the best moments pta puts to
film are the ones where he sits these
characters down after having built up a
history between them and simply lets us
watch these complex beautiful and flawed
human dynamics play out on screen
[Music]
this video is sponsored by mubi and i'm
very excited to highlight a film that's
streaming exclusively on mubi right now
terence malik's imax documentary voyage
of time came out in theaters in 2016 and
it's been almost impossible to find
anywhere since then but now for the
first time it's streaming on mubi and
you can watch it right now if you sign
up for a 30-day free trial by going to
mubi.com
thomasflight this documentary is really
cool it's like a feature-length
expansion of the creation sequence from
tree of life the visuals are stunning
and luckily it's streaming in 4k on mubi
right now mubi is a hand curated online
streaming cinema with an amazing
collection of films from around the
globe and releases like voyage of time
are a big reason why i'm a huge fan of
what they do they're going out of their
way to bring us worthwhile films that
can be difficult to find anywhere else
you get a special extended 30-day free
trial when you go to mubi.com
thomasflight check out voyage of time or
look through their amazing library to
discover something new today thanks
again to mubi for sponsoring this video
[Music]
you